[Music]
[Music]
welcome on behalf of the program in
writing and humanistic studies and the
Center for bilingual and bicultural
studies when I see a photograph of
Jhumpa Lahiri in the New York Times or
The New Yorker
I don't think hot young fiction writer
but instead friend of my daughter Marnie
and I remember the year or so the jumpa
and Marnie worked at Wordsworth
bookstore in Cambridge they tore up the
place I like to go in and browse just to
hear them laugh they were that they were
at that stage of discovering their
friendship when everything is hilarious
I can still hear them ball out oh my god
at some juicy bit of gossip or
off-the-charts exploit some time after
this jumpa asked me to read one of her
early stories I did so felt lukewarm
about it and told herself she never
showed me another one of her stories I
respect her for this writers ought to be
ruthless about their art and they need
to know where to go to get what they
require jumpa began to find what she
needed while in the BU Writing Program
and more and more in herself as one
thing led to another and with the
publication of interpreter of maladies
she became a star she began as a
paperback writer and graduated to
hardcover who knows how this happened
bad things happen to good writers and
when good things happen to deserving
ones it's not easy to figure out why a
possible explanation occurred to be when
I began to see jumpa grouped with Indian
and Asian writers her work tells at
least on one level the old American tale
of here and there the old country and
the new world the tale that has been
ours since the great emigration at the
end of the 19th and beginning of the
20th century the tale told by Saul
Bellow and James Baldwin by Jamaica
Kincaid and writers will leap into all
your minds
it is the American story of who we are
how we know it and the anxieties and
exhilaration is involved not that this
answers the question which in the end
does not matter jumpers work has struck
a nerve or you wouldn't be here
jumpa the audience is yours
Wow good evening I am very pleased to be
here thank you all for coming
I want to thank when I thank everyone at
MIT for having me here tonight
mit was some of you may know the first
place my father worked in this country
when he moved here with me and my mother
in 1969 and I'm honored that it's the
first University in Boston that's asked
me to read I especially want to thank
bill and his wife Beverly Corbett
I want to thank bill for his very kind
words just now but but for their efforts
and their generosity and their
incredible hospitality which I've been a
recipient of for a long time now
I first met them 11 years ago right
around this time of year as as bill
mentioned I was I am a friend of their
daughter Marni's and at the time I just
moved to Boston I just graduated from
college and I moved to Cambridge and I
was living in a room of the home of a
woman with these two shall we say very
strident young children and I sort of
lived in this little room behind their
living room and felt very very not at
home there were all sorts of rules I had
to abide by
I couldn't have visitors after a certain
hour I had to wipe down the stove every
time I make boiled water for tea all of
these things was not a very ideal
situation and it was around that time
that Marnie invited me to dinner at her
parents house I remember it was a Sunday
night and I had directions to go to the
South End I never been to the South End
before I got on the orange line and went
the wrong way found myself heading
rapidly toward Oak Grove turned back
around and made it eventually to their
house and was immediately just so struck
those first weeks of my life in Boston
were very you know they weren't too
Pleasant and all of a sudden I felt
wonderfully at home and I discovered a
beautiful home and beautiful people and
good food and rules that were decidedly
relaxed compared to my my own lodgings
and that was the first of many nights I
spent in their home and many delicious
dinners I ate at their table another of
which I'm about to have in a few hours
I'm looking forward to it and I also
want to say that it was also around this
time that I went to my my first reading
in Boston and that was one of bills
readings he was reading from his book on
Blue Note up at Harvard and I remember
going with Marnie and Beverly and
feeling very excited about this until I
met bill I hadn't known a writer before
writers were to me names on the covers
of books but they weren't people and I
was amazed over the months that I grew
to new their family and here was this
man who had a family and a house and
wrote all these books and had a life and
even managed this for all these amazing
dinner parties and so I want to thank
him for that wonderful example and I
think that if I could write half as many
books and throw half as many successful
dinner parties I will be very grateful
anyway so after Bill asked me to come up
here I realized this had not occurred to
me until then but I realized that I
mentioned MIT and not one but two of the
stories in my book
go figure I didn't
here but I thought I'd read from one of
them in honor of my being here tonight
this one is called this blessed house
I'll read the whole thing they
discovered the first one in a cupboard
above the stove beside an unopened
bottle of malt vinegar guess what I
found
twinkle said she walked into the living
room lined from end to end with taped up
packing boxes waving the vinegar in one
hand and a white porcelain effigy of
Christ roughly the same size as the
vinegar bottle in the other Sanjeev
looked up he was kneeling on the floor
marking with ripped bits of a post-it
patches on the baseboard that needed to
be retouched with paint throw it away
which both but I can cook something with
the vinegar it's brand new you've never
cooked anything with vinegar
I'll look something up in one of those
books we got for our wedding
Sanjeev took turned back to the
baseboard to replace a post at scrap
that had fallen to the floor check the
expiration and at the very least get rid
of that idiotic statue but it could be
worth something who knows she turned it
upside down then stroked with her index
finger the miniscule frozen folds of his
robes it's pretty we're not Christian
Sanjeev said lately had begun to notice
the need to state the obvious to twinkle
the day before he had to tell her that
if she dragged her end of the bureau
instead of lifting it the parquet floor
would scratch she shrugged no we're not
Christian we're good little Hindus she
planted a kiss on top of Christ's head
then placed the statue on top of the
fireplace mantel which needed Sanjeev
observed to be dusted by the end of the
week the mantel had still not been
dusted it had however come to serve as a
display shelf for a sizeable collection
of Christian paraphernalia
there was a 3d postcard of st. Francis
done in four colors which twinkle had
found taped to the
of the medicine cabinet and a wooden
cross keychain which Sanjeev had stepped
on with bare feet as he was installing
extra shelving in twinkle study there
was a framed paint by number of the
three wise men against a black velvet
background tucked in the linen closet
there was also a tiled trivet depicting
a blonde unbe R did Jesus delivering a
sermon on a mountaintop left in one of
the drawers of the built in china
cabinet in the dining room do you think
the previous owners were born against us
twinkle making room the next day for a
small plastic snow filled dome
containing a miniature nativity scene
found behind the pipes of the kitchen
sink sanjeev was organizing his
engineering texts from MIT in
alphabetical order on a bookshelf though
it had been several years and si had
needed to consult any of them after
graduating he moved from Boston to
Connecticut to work for a firm near
Hartford and he had recently learned
that he was being considered for the
position of vice president at 33 he had
a secretary of his own and dozen of
people working under his supervision who
gladly supplied him with any information
he needed
still the presence of his college books
in the room reminded him of a time in
his life he recalled with fondness when
he would walk each evening across the
mass Avenue Bridge in order to order
moogle I'd chicken with spinach from his
favorite Indian restaurant on the other
side of the Charles and returned to his
dorm to write out clean copies of his
problem sets or perhaps it's an attempt
to convert people twinkle mused clearly
the scheme has succeeded in your case
she disregarded him shaking the little
plastic dome so that snow swirled over
the manger he studied the items on the
mantle it puzzled him that each was in
its own way so silly clearly they lacked
a sense of sacredness he was further
puzzled that twinkle who normally
displayed good taste was so charmed
these objects meant something to twinkle
but they meant nothing to him they
irritated him we should call the realtor
tell him there's all this nonsense
behind tell him to take it away Oh sonj
twinkle groaned please I would feel
terrible throwing them away
obviously they were important to the
people who used to live here
it would feel I don't know sacrilegious
or something if they're so precious then
why are they hidden all over the house
why didn't they take them with them
there must be others twinkle said her
eyes room the bear off white walls of
the room as if there were other things
concealed behind the plaster what else
do you think we'll find but as they
unpack their boxes and hung up their
winter clothes and the silk paintings of
elephant processions bought on their
honeymoon enjoy poor twinkle much to her
dismay could not find a thing nearly a
week had passed before they discovered
one Sunday one Saturday afternoon a
larger than life sized watercolor poster
of Christ
we've been translucent tears the size of
peanut shells and sporting a crown of
thorns rolled up behind a radiator in
the guest bedroom
Sanjeev had mistaken it for a window
shade oh we must we simply must put it
up it's too spectacular
twinkle little cigarette and began to
smoke it with relish waving it around
sanjeev's head as if it were a
conductors baton as Mahler's fifth
symphony award from the stereo
downstairs now look I will tolerate for
now your little biblical menagerie in
the living room but I refuse to have
this he said flicking at one of the
painted peanut tiers displayed in our
home
twinkle stared at him placidly exhaling
the smoke emerging in two thin blue
streams from her nostrils she rolled up
the poster slowly securing it with one
of the elastic bands she always wore
around her wrists for tying back her
thick unruly hair streaked here and
there with henna I'm going to put it in
my study she informed him that way you
don't have to look at it what about the
housewarming they'll want to see all the
rooms I've invited people from the
office she rolled her eyes Sanjeev noted
that the symphony now in its third
movement had reached a crescendo for it
pulsed with the telltale clashing of
cymbals
I'll put it behind the door she offered
that way when they peek in they won't
see happy
he stood watching her as she left the
room with her poster and her cigarette a
few ashes had fallen to the floor where
she'd been standing he bent down pinched
them between his fingers and deposited
them in his cupped palm the tender
fourth movement the Adagio began during
breakfast sanjeev had read in the liner
notes that Mahler had proposed to his
wife by sending her the manuscript of
this portion of the score although there
were elements of tragedy and struggle in
the fifth symphony he had read it was
principally music of love and happiness
he heard the toilet flush by the way
twinkle hollered if you want to impress
people I wouldn't play this music it's
putting me to sleep
Sanjeev went to the bathroom to throw
away the ashes the cigarette butts still
bobbed in the toilet bowl but the tank
was refilling so he had to wait a moment
before he could flush it again in the
mirror of the medicine cabinet he
inspected his long eyelashes like a
girl's twinkle liked to tease though he
was of average build his cheeks had a
plumpness to them this along with the
eyelashes detracted he feared from what
he hoped was a distinguished profile he
was of average height as well and wished
ever since he had stopped growing that
he were just one inch taller for this
reason it irritated him when Twinkle
insisted on wearing high heels as she
had done the other night when they ate
dinner in Manhattan this was the first
weekend after they'd moved into the
house by then the mantle had already
filled up considerably and they had Bick
heard about it in the car on the way
down but then twinkle had drunk four
glasses of whiskey in a nameless bar in
Alphabet City and forgot all about it
she dragged him to a tiny bookshop on
st. Mark's Place where she browsed for
nearly an hour and when they left she
insisted they dance a tango on the
sidewalk in front of strangers
afterwards she tottered on his arm
rising faintly over his line of vision
in a pair of suede three-inch leopard
print pumps in this manner they walked
the endless blocks back to a parking
garage on Washington Square for Sanjeev
had heard far too many stories about the
terrible things that happened to cars in
Manhattan but I do nothing all day
except sit at my desk she fretted when
they were driving home after he
mentioned that her shoes looked
uncomfortable and suggested that perhaps
she should not wear them I can't exactly
wear heels when I'm typing though he
abandoned the argument he knew for a
fact that she didn't spend all day at
her desk just that afternoon when he got
back from a run he found her
inexplicably in bed reading when he
asked her why she was in bed in the
middle of the day she told him she was
bored he had wanted to say to her then
you can unpack some boxes you could
sweep the Attic
you could retouch the paint on the
bathroom windowsill
and after you do it you could warn me so
I don't put my watch on it they didn't
bother her these scattered unsettled
matters she seemed content with whatever
clothes she found at the front of the
closet with whatever magazine was lying
around with whatever song was on the
radio content yet curious and now all of
her curiosity centered around
discovering the next treasure a few days
later when sanjeev returned from the
office he found twinkle on the telephone
smoking and talking to one of her
girlfriends in california even though it
must be four or five o'clock and the
long-distance rates were at their peak
highly devout people she was saying
pausing every now and then to exhale
each day is like a treasure hunt I'm
serious this you won't believe the
switch plates in the bedroom were
decorated with scenes from the Bible
you know Noah's Ark and all that three
bedrooms but one is in my study but one
is my study sanjeev went to the hardware
store right away and replaced them can
you imagine he replaced every single one
now it was the friends turn to talk
twinkle nodded slouched on the floor in
front of the fridge wearing black
stirrup pants and a yellow chenille
sweater groping for her lighter sanjeev
could smell something aromatic on the
stove and he picked his way carefully
across the extra-long phone cord tangled
on the mexican terracotta tiles he
opened the lid of a pot with some sort
of reddish brown sauce dripping over the
sides boiling furiously it's a stew I
made with the fish I put the vinegar in
it she said to him interrupting her
friend crossing her fingers sorry you
were saying she was like that excited
and delighted by little things crossing
her fingers before any remotely
unpredictable event like tasting a new
flavor of ice cream or dropping a letter
in a mailbox it was a quality he did not
understand it made him feel stupid as if
the world contained hidden wonders he
could not anticipate or see he looked at
her face which it occurred to him had
not grown out of its girlhood the eyes
untroubled the pleasing features unfirm
as if they still had to settle into some
sort of permanent expression nicknamed
after a nursery rhyme she had yet to
shed a childhood endearment now in the
second month of their marriage certain
things nettled him the way she sometimes
spat a little when she spoke or left her
undergarments after removing them at
night at the foot of their bed rather
than depositing them in the laundry
hamper they had met only four months
before her parents who lived in
California and his who still lived in
Calcutta world friends and across
continents they had arranged the
occasion at which twinkle and sand Jeep
were introduced a 16th birthday party
for a daughter in their circle when
Sanjeev was in Palo Alto on business at
the restaurant they were seated side by
side at a round table with a revolving
platter of spareribs and egg rolls and
chicken wings which they concurred all
tasted the same they had concurred too
on their adolescent but still persistent
fondness for wood house novels and their
dislike for the sitar and later twinkle
confessed that she was charmed by the
way Sanjeev had doodlee dutifully
refilled her tea cup during their
conversation and so the phone calls
began and grew longer and then the
visits first he to Stanford then she to
Connecticut after which Sanjeev would
save in an ashtray left on the balcony
the crushed cigarettes she had smoked
during the weekend saved them that is
until the next time she came to visit
him and then he vacuumed the apartment
washed the sheets even dusted the plant
leaves in her honor she was 27 and
recently abandoned he gathered by an
American who had tried and failed to be
an actor Sanjeev was lonely with an
excessively generous income for a single
man and had never been in love at the
urging of their matchmakers they married
in India I made hundreds of well-wishers
whom he barely remembered from his
childhood in incessant August rains
under a red and orange tent strung with
Christmas tree lights on Mandeville Road
did you sweep the Attic he asked twinkle
later as she was folding the paper now
Hawkins and wedging them by their plates
the Attic was the only part of the house
they had not yet given an initial
cleaning not yet I promise I will
I hope this tastes good she said
planting the steaming pot on top of the
juices trivet there was a loaf of
Italian bread in a little basket and
iceberg lettuce and grated carrots
tossed with bottle dressing and croutons
and glasses of red wine she was not
terribly ambitious in the kitchen she
bought pre roasted chickens from the
supermarket and served them with potato
salad prepared who knew when sold in
little plastic containers Indian food
she complained was a bother she detested
chopping garlic and peeling ginger and
could not operate a blender and so it
was Sanjeev who on weekends seasoned
mustard oil with cinnamon sticks and
cloves in order to produce a proper
curry he had to admit though that
whatever it was that she had cooked
today it was unusually tasty attractive
even with bright white cubes of fish and
flecks of parsley and fresh tomatoes
gleaming in the dark brown red broth how
did you make it I made it up what did
you do I just put some things into the
pot and added the malt vinegar at the
end how much vinegar she shrugged
ripping off some bread and plunging it
into her bowl what do you mean you don't
know you should write it down what if
you need to make it again for a party or
something I'll remember she said she
covered the bread basket with a dish
towel that had he suddenly noticed the
10 commandments printed on it she
flashed him a little smile giving his me
a little squeeze under the table face it
this house is blessed
the housewarming party was scheduled for
the last Saturday in October and they
had invited about 30 people all over
sanjeev's acquaintances people from the
office and a number of Indian couples in
the Connecticut area many of whom he
barely knew but who had regularly
invited him in his bachelor days to
supper on Saturdays he often wondered
why they included him in their circle he
had little in common with any of them
but he was always a he but he always
attended their gatherings
to eat spicy chickpea and shrimp cutlets
and gossip and discuss politics where he
seldom had other plans so far no one had
met twinkle back when they were still
dating sanjeev didn't want to waste
their brief weekends together with
people he associated with being alone
other than Sanjeev and an ex-boyfriend
who she believed worked in a pottery
studio in Brookfield she knew no one in
the state of Connecticut she was
completing her master's thesis at
Stanford a study of an Irish poet whom
some jeev had never heard of Sanjeev had
found the house on his own before
leaving for the wedding for a good price
in a neighborhood with a fine school
system he was impressed by the elegant
curved staircase with its wrought iron
banister and the dark wooden wainscoting
and the solarium overlooking
rhododendron bushes and the solid brass
tutu which also happened to be the date
of his birth nailed impressively to the
vaguely Tudor facade there were two
working fireplaces a two-car garage and
an attic suitable for converting into
extra bedrooms
if the realtor mentioned the need should
arise by then sanjeev had already made
up his mind was determined that he and
twinkle should live there together
forever and so he had not bothered to
notice the switch plates covered with
biblical stickers for the transparent
decal of the Virgin on the half-shell
ass Winkle liked to call it
adhere to the window in the master
bedroom when after moving in he tried to
scrape it off he scratched the glass the
weekend before the party they were
raking the lawn when he heard
twinkle shriek he ran to her crotch
clutching his rake worried that she had
discovered a dead animal or a snake a
brisk October breeze stung the tops of
his ears as his sneakers crunched over
brown and yellow leaves when he reached
her she had collapsed on the grass
dissolved in nearly silent laughter
behind an overgrown forsythia bush was a
plaster version Mary as tall as their
waists with a blue painted hood draped
over her head in the manner of an Indian
bride twinkle grabbed at the hem of her
t-shirt and began wiping away the dirt
staining the statues brow I suppose you
want to put her by the foot of our bed
she looked at him astonished her belly
was exposed and he saw that there were
goose bumps around her navel what do you
think of course we can't put this in our
bedroom we can't
no silly sonj business meant for outside
oh god no twinkle no but we must it
would be bad luck not to all the
neighbors will see they'll think we're
insane why for having a statue of the
Virgin Mary on our lawn every other
person in this neighborhood has a statue
of Mary on the lawn will fit right in
we're not Christian so you keep
reminding me she spat onto the tip of
her finger and started to rub intently
at a particularly stubborn stain on
Mary's chin do you think this is dirt or
some kind of fungus he was getting
nowhere with her with this woman whom he
had known only for four months and whom
he had married this woman with whom he
now shared his life he thought with a
flicker of regret of the snapshots his
mother used to send him from Calcutta a
prospective brides who could sing and
sew and seasoned lentils without
consulting a cookbook
Sanjeev had considered these women had
even ranked them in order of preference
but then he'd met twinkle-twinkle I
can't have the people I work with Sivas
statue on my lawn they can't fire you
for being a believer it would be
discrimination that's not the point
why does it matter to you so much what
other people think twinkle please he was
tired he let his weight rest against his
rake she began dragging the statue
toward an oval bed of myrtle beside the
lamppost that flanked the brick pathway
looks and she's so lovely he returned to
his pile of leaves and began to deposit
them by handfuls into a plastic garbage
bag over his head the blue sky was
cloudless one tree on the lawn was still
full of leaves red and orange like the
tent in which he had married twinkle he
did not know if he loved her he said he
did when she first asked him one
afternoon in Palo Alto as they sat side
by side in a darkened nearly empty movie
theater before the film one of her
favorites something in German that he
found extremely depressing
she had pressed the tip
knows to his so that it could feel the
flutter of her mascara coated eyelashes
that afternoon he had replied yes he
loved her and she was delighted and fed
him a piece of popcorn lending her
finger linger an instant between his
lips as if it were her if as if it were
his reward for coming up with the right
answer though she did not say it herself
he assumed that she loved him too but
now he was no longer sure in truth
Sanjeev did not know what love was only
what he thought it was not it was not he
had decided returning to an empty
carpeted condominium each night and
using only the top fork in his cutlery
drawer and turning away politely at
those weekend dinner parties when the
other men eventually put their arms
around the wastes of their wives and
girlfriends leaning over every now and
then to kiss their shoulders or necks it
was not sending away for classical
musical CDs by male working his way from
ethically through the major composers
but the catalogue recommended and always
sending his payments in on time in the
months before meeting sanjeev meaning
twinkle sanjeev had begun to realize
this you have enough money in the bank
to raise three families his mother
reminded him when they spoke at the
start of each month on the phone you
need a wife to look after and love now
he had won a pretty one from a suitably
high cast who would soon have a master's
degree what was there not to love
that evening Sanjeev poured himself a
gin and tonic drank it and most of
another during one segment of the news
and then approached twinkle who was
taking a bubble bath for she announced
that her limbs ached from raking the
lawn something she had never done before
he didn't knock she had applied a bright
blue mask to her face was smoking and
sipping some bourbon with ice and
leaving through a fat paperback book
whose pages had buckled and turned gray
from the water he glanced at the cover
the only thing written on it was the
word sonnets in dark red letters he took
a breath and then he informed her very
calmly that after finishing his drink he
was going to put on his shoes and go
outside and remove the virgin
from the front lawn where are you going
to put it she asked him dreamily her
eyes closed one of her legs emerged
unfolding gracefully from the layer of
suds she flexed and pointed her toes for
now I'm going to put it in the garage
then tomorrow morning on my way to work
I'm going to take it to the dump
don't you dare she stood up letting the
book fall into the water bubbles
dripping down her thighs I hate you she
informed him her eyes narrowing at the
word hate she reached for her bathrobe
tied it tightly about her waist and
patted down the winding staircase
leaving sloppy wet footprints along the
parquet floor when she reached the foyer
sanjeev said are you planning on leaving
the house that way he felt a throbbing
in his temples and his voice revealed an
unfamiliar snarl when he spoke who cares
who cares what way I leave this house
where are you planning on going at this
hour you can't throw away that statue I
won't let you her mask now dry had
assumed a national 'ti and water from
her hair dripped onto the caked contours
of her face yes I can I will
no twinkle said her voice suddenly small
this is our house we own it together the
statue is a part of our property she had
begun to shiver a small pool of bath
water had collected around her ankles he
went to shut a window fearing that she
would catch cold then he noticed that
some of the water dripping down her hard
blue face was tears oh God twinkle
please I didn't mean it he had never
seen her cry before had never seen such
sadness in her eyes she didn't turn away
or try to stop the tears instead she
looked strangely at peace for a moment
she closed her lids pale and unprotected
compared to the blue that caked the rest
of her face Sanji felt ill as if he had
eaten either too much or too little she
went to him placing her damp towel arms
about her net about his neck sobbing
into his chest soaking his shirt
the math flaked onto his shoulders in
the end they settled on a compromise the
statue would be placed in a recess at
the side of the house so that it wasn't
obvious to passers-by but was still
clearly visible to all who came the menu
for the party was fairly simple there
would be a case of champagne and samosas
from an Indian restaurant in Hartford
and big trays of rice with chicken and
almonds and orange peels which Sanjeev
had spent the greater part of the
morning and afternoon preparing he had
never entertained on such a large scale
before and worried that there would not
be enough to drink ran out at one point
to buy another case of champagne just in
case for this reason he burned one of
the rice trays and had to start it over
again twinkle swept the floors and
volunteered to pick up the samosas she
had an appointment for a manicure and a
pedicure in that direction anyway
Sanjeev had planned to ask if she would
consider clearing the menagerie off the
mantel if only for the party but she had
left while he was in the shower she was
gone for a good three hours and so it
was Sanjeev who did the rest of the
cleaning by 5:30 the entire house
sparkled with scented candles that
twinkle had picked up in Hartford
illuminating the items on the mantel and
slender stalks of burning incense
planted in the into the soil of potted
plants each time he passed the mantel he
winced dreading the raised eyebrows of
his guests as they viewed the flickering
ceramic saints the salt and pepper
shakers designed to resemble Mary and
Joseph
still they would be impressed he hoped
by the lovely bay windows the shining
parquet floors the impressive winding
staircase the wooden wainscoting as they
shipped as they sipped champagne and
dipped samosas into chutney
Douglas one of the new consultants of
the firm and his girlfriend Nora were
the first to arrive
both were tall and blonde wearing
matching wire-rimmed glasses and long
black overcoats Nora wore a black hat
full of sharp thin feathers that
corresponded to the sharp thin angles of
her face her left hand was joined with
Douglass's in her right hand with a
bottle of cognac with a red ribbon
wrapped around its neck which she gave
to twinkle great lawn sanjeev douglas
remarked we've got to get that ray car
out ourselves sweetie and this must be
my wife
toni ma call me twinkle what an unusual
name Nora remarked twinkle shrugged not
really there's an actress in Bombay came
dimple kapadia she even has a sister
named simple Douglas and Nora raised
their eyebrows simultaneously nodding
slowly as if to let the absurdity of the
name settle in please to meet you
twinkle help yourself to champagne
there's gallons I hope you don't mind my
asking Douglas said but I noticed a
statue outside and are you his Christian
I thought you were Indian there are
Christians in India Sanjeev replied but
we're not I love your outfit Nora so
it's told twinkle and I adore your hat
which you left the Grand Tour the bell
rang again and again and again within
minutes it seemed the house had filled
with bodies and conversations and
unfamiliar fragrances the women wore
heels and sheer stockings and short
black dresses made of crepe and chip and
chiffon they handed their wraps and
codes to Sanjeev who draped them
carefully on hangers in this spacious
coat closet though twinkle-toed told
people to throw their things on the
Ottomans in the solarium
some of the Indian women were their
finest saris made with gold filigree
that draped in elegant pleats over their
shoulders the men wore jackets and ties
and citrus-scented aftershaves
as people filtered from one room to the
next
presents piled onto the long cherry wood
table that ran from one end of the
downstairs hall to the other it
bewildered sanjeev's that it was for him
and his house and his wife that they had
all gone to so much care the only other
time in his life that something similar
had happened was his wedding but somehow
this was different
for these were not his family but people
who knew him only casually and in a
sense
owed him nothing everyone congratulated
him lester another co-worker predicted
that sanjeev would be promoted to
vice-president in two months maximum
people devoured the samosas and
dutifully admired the freshly painted
ceilings and walls the hanging plants
the bay windows the silk paintings from
joy poor but most of all they admired
twinkle and her Brooke hated salwar
kameez which was the shade of a
persimmon with a low scoop in the back
and a little string of white rose petals
she had coiled cleverly around her head
and the pearl choker with a sapphire at
its center that adorned her throat over
hectic jazz records played under
twinkles supervision they laughed at her
anecdotes and observations forming a
widening circle around her while Sanjeev
replenished the samosas that he kept
warming in the oven and getting ice for
people's drinks and opening more bottles
of champagne with some difficulty and
explaining for the 40th time that he
wasn't Christian it was twinkle who led
them in separate groups up and down the
winding staircase to gaze at the back
lawn to peer down the cellar steps your
friends adorn the poster in my study she
mentioned to him triumphantly placing
her hand on the small of his back as
they at one point brushed past each
other
Sanjeev went to the kitchen which was
empty and ate a piece of chicken out of
the tray on the counter with his fingers
because he thought no one was looking he
a second piece then washed it down with
a gulp of gin straight from the bottle
great house great rice Sunil an
anesthesiologist walked in spooning food
from his paper plate into his mouth Jim
more champagne
your wife's Wow added pro ball following
behind
he was an unmarried professor of physics
at Yale for a moment Sanjeev stared at
him blankly then blushed once at a
dinner party pro ball had pronounced the
Sophia Loren was Wow
as was Audrey Hepburn does she have a
sister Chanel picked a raisin out of the
rice tray is her last name little star
the two men laughed and started eating
more rice from the tray plowing through
it with their plastic spoons
Sanjeev went down to the cellar for more
liquor for a few minutes he paused on
the steps in the damp cool silence
hugging the second crate of champagne to
his chest as the party drifted above the
rafters then he set the reinforcements
on the dining table yes everything we
found them all in the house in the most
unusual places
he heard twinkle saying in the living
room in fact we keep finding them no yes
every day is like a treasure hunt it's
too good god only knows what else we'll
find no pun intended
that was what started it as if by some
unspoken pact the whole party joined
forces and began combing through each of
the world opening closets on their own
peering under chairs and cushions
feeling behind curtains removing books
from bookcases groups scampered giggling
and swaying up and down the winding
staircase we've never explored the Attic
twinkling out suddenly and so everybody
followed how do we get up there there's
a ladder in the hallway somewhere in the
ceiling wearily sanji followed at the
back of the crowd to point out the
location of the ladder but twinkle had
already found it on her own
Eureka she hollered Douglas pulled the
chain that released the steps his face
was flushed and he was wearing Nora's
feather hat on his head one by one the
guests disappeared men helping women as
they place their strappy high heels on
the narrow slats of the ladder the
Indian women wrapping the free ends of
their expensive saris into their waist
bands the men followed behind all
quickly disappearing until Sanjeev alone
remained at the top of the winding
staircase footsteps thundered over his
head he had no desire to join them he
wondered if the ceiling would collapse
imagined for a split second the sight of
all the tumbling drunk perfumed bodies
crashing tangled around him he heard a
shriek and then rising spreading waves
of laughter in discordant tones
something fell something else shattered
he could hear them babbling about a
trunk they seemed to be struggling to
get it open
banging feverishly on its surface he
thought perhaps twinkle would call for
his assistance but he was not summoned
he looked about the hallway and to the
landing below at the champagne glasses
and half-eaten samosas and napkins
smeared with lipstick abandoned in every
corner on every available surface then
he noticed the twinkle in her haste had
discarded her shoes altogether for they
lay by the foot of the ladder black
patent-leather mules with heels like
golf tees open toes and slightly soiled
silk
Able's on the instep where her soles had
rested he placed them in the doorway of
the master bedroom so that no one would
trip when they when they descended he
heard something creaking open slowly the
strident voices that voices had subsided
to an even murmur it occurred to Sanjeev
that he had the house all to himself the
music had ended and he could hear if he
concentrated the hum of the refrigerator
and the rustle of the last leaves on the
trees outside and the tapping of their
branches against the windowpanes
with one flick of his hand he could snap
the ladder back on it spring into the
ceiling and they would have no way of
getting down unless he were to pull the
chain and let them he thought of all the
things he could do undisturbed he could
sweep twinkles menagerie into a garbage
bag and get in the car and drive it to
the dump
and tear down the poster of weeping
Jesus and took a hammer to the Virgin
Mary while he was added then he would
return to the empty house he could
easily clear up the cups and plates in
an hour's time and pour himself a gin
and tonic and a plate of warmed white
and listen to his new Bach CD while
reading the liner notes so as to
understand it properly he nudged the
ladder slightly but it was sturdily
planted against the floor budging it
would require some effort my god I need
a cigarette twinkled exclaimed from
above
Sanjeev felt knots forming at the back
of his neck he felt dizzy he needed to
lie down he walked toward the bedroom
but stopped short when he saw twinkle
shoes facing him in the doorway he
thought of her slipping them on her feet
but instead of feeling irritated as he
had ever since they'd moved into the
house together he felt a pang of
anticipation at the thought of her
rushing unsteadily down the winding
staircase in them scratching the floor a
bit in her path the pang intensified as
he thought of her rushing to the
bathroom to brighten her lipstick and
eventually rushing to get people their
coats and finally rushing to the
cherrywood table when the last guests
had left to begin opening their house
presence it was the same pang he used to
feel before they were married
when he would hang up the phone after
one of their conversations or when he
would drive back from the airport
wondering which ascending plane in the
sky was hers Sanj you won't believe this
she emerged with her back to him her
hands over her head the tops of her bare
shoulder blades perspiring supporting
something still hidden from view
you got a twinkle someone asked yes you
can let go now he saw that her hands
were wrapped around it a solid silver
bust of Christ the head easily three
times the size of his own it had a
patrician bump on its nose magnificent
curly hair that rested atop a pronounced
collarbone and a broad forehead that
reflected in miniature the walls and
doors and lampshades around them its
expression was confident as if assured
of its devotees the unyielding lips
sensuous and full it was also sporting
Nora's feather hat a sprinkle descended
Sangeeth put his hands around her waist
to balance her and he relieved her of
the bust when she had reached the ground
it weighed a good thirty pounds the
others began lowering themselves slowly
exhausted from the hunt some trickled
downstairs in search of a fresh drink
she took a breath raised her eyebrows
crossed her fingers would you mind
terribly if we displayed it on the
mantel
just for tonight I know you hate it he
did hate it he hated its immensity and
it's flawless polished surface and it's
undeniable value he hated that it was in
his house and that he owned it unlike
the other things they'd found this
contained dignity solemnity beauty even
but to his surprise these qualities made
him hate it all the more most of all he
hated it because he knew that twinkle
loved it I'll keep it in my study from
tomorrow to inkle added I promise she
would never put it in her study he knew
for the rest of their days together she
would keep it on the center
mantel flanked on either side but the
rest of the menagerie each time they had
guests twinkle would explain how she'd
found it and they would admire her as
they listened he gazed at the crushed
rose petals in her hair and the pearl
and sapphire choker at her throat at the
sparkly crimson polish on her toes
he decided that these were among the
things that made propre Ball think she
was well his head ached from Jin and his
arms ache from the weight of the statue
he said I put your shoes in the bedroom
thanks but my feet are killing me
Twinkle gave his elbow a little squeezed
and headed for the living room
Sanjeev pressed the massive silver face
to his ribs careful not to let the
feather hat slip and followed her thank
you
[Applause]